[Musik]
hast du bis zum knie du musst doch was
zu abschlüssen haben kostet ab und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut heute
haben wir was interessantes vor es hört
sich vielleicht man muss sagen das hört
sich vielleicht erst mal gar nicht so
spektakulär an und ich kann auch nicht
sagen ob es so spektakulär wird ich
hoffe es natürlich um direkt zum thema
zu kommen mir wurde vor einiger zeit ein
video bei dem zugesteckt vor dem
zuschauer und der warentester dass auf
jeden fall immer ab und man muss ja
sagen auch instagram wird mir sehr sehr
oft irgendwas zu geschichtlich sagt das
ja auch immer vieles davon ist jetzt
nicht so heiß also da weiß ich nichts
mit anzufangen es gibt aber auch eine
menge sachen die sind cool also wenn ich
irgendein produkt haben was ich mal
testen leuchtmann es auf jeden fall bei
installieren das produkt um das ist
heute geht habe mich wirklich fasziniert
ich glaube das lager braucht so ein
bisschen an dem video was halt das
produkt dann beinhaltet das werbevideo
dazu sage ich mal so und ich würde sagen
ich zeige euch das mal ganz kurz kann
ich machen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
ja und so weiter so ein guter brauch
geht direkt ins ohr
das war jetzt selber ich hoffe das video
will das nicht wegen dem beat gesperrten
fenster gestürzt oder so alle leute
updates gesehen es handelt sich um ein
ladekabel und zwar soll das das
unzerstörbare ladekabel sein also ich
habe mich natürlich auch ein bisschen
mit dem produkt auseinander gesetzt
bevor ich halt gekauft hat habe dann im
internet bestellt für 10 11 12 euro oder
so linkt frage ich euch sehr gerne in
die video beschreibung und das ist jetzt
angekommen und ich habe mir gedacht wir
testen das auf jeden fall mal weil wir
haben ja gestern im video und darüber
beklagt wir haben erstens kaum ein
iphone ladekabel
viele gehen schnell kaputt manche
verschwinden einfach so und dieses kabel
das hat halt auf der einen seite
natürlich coole features die ich euch
dann gleich hoffentlich vorstellen kann
und auf der anderen seite geht es nicht
kaputt zumindest laut des videos wir
werden das man testen ich habe mir ein
paar sachen geholt wir können uns auch
gerne mal irgendwie da dranhängen
sogleich oder ich ziehe mein auto damit
so weil ich wahrscheinlich mein auto gar
nicht ziehen kann
weil das waren ja alles diese sachen die
uns gerade hier im werbevideo gezeigt
wurden und da bin ich jetzt einfach mal
gespannt ob das funktioniert natürlich
nein wir haben auch schon das produkt
also ich hab es in erster linie für mein
iphone bestellt deswegen auch in
lightning habe gewählt da gibt es auch
ein usb kabel und wieder ganze quatsch
es also da gibt's verschiedene
anschlüsse muss man dann halt nur das
passende auswählen und ich glaube das
gibt es auch in verschiedenen längen ich
habe jetzt 1,2 meter ausgewählt
eigentlich habe ich gedacht ich habe
drei mit gut ist aber erstmal nicht so
wichtig sagt warten wirs mal aus okay
und wir haben was dann auch schon sieht
erstmal relativ unspektakulär aus ist
halt auch irgendwo dann immer noch
einfach nur ein ladekabel habe ich muss
sagen der erste eindruck ist auf jeden
fall schon mal nicht schlecht das ist
natürlich auch mal das problem bei den
originalen kabeln wenn man die so oft
knick und so habe ich jetzt keinem einem
wieder das problem das ist hier kommt
nicht wieder aufgegangen
und irgendwann entsteht der erste
wackelkontakt bis es dann irgendwann gar
nicht mehr geht
oder ist natürlich scheiße das ist
wahrscheinlich auf extras ohne dass man
immer wieder neue kabel kauft kann das
sein juni heute möchte er nicht reden
ok dann würde ich sagen wir brauchen mal
kurz
strom das machen wir jetzt anwenden weil
jemals ein stromproblem haben das
verlängerungskabel unsere theorie auf
die geniale idee gekommen
ich sollte mein laptop nimmt ausgeben
möchte ich mal kurz das erste feature
präsentieren was ich gesehen habe als
ich mich ein bisschen damit beschäftigt
habe ich meine schaut mal leute das
passiert auch andauernd dass man den
adapter mit dem kabel verbinden möchte
oder dann funktioniert das nicht direkt
jetzt komischerweise direkt funktioniert
weil ich das nämlich raus
drees auf einmal um und es geht wieder
genial
ich habe mich schon so oft aufgeregt
dass ich mich wieder drehen musste also
meine hand wieder drehen musste weil das
kabel nicht gepasst hat
hier hat man das problem nicht mehr
jetzt halt mal dass in wie das innen
aussieht also falls doch einmal ansehen
kannst hier so sieht das von innen aus
das heißt dieses weiße dinge zwischen
schiebt sicherheit immer automatisch auf
die richtige seite
das ist immer passt nächstes feature war
ihr connecten das jetzt mit dem laptop
wir haben hier ihr seht ihr jetzt schon
hier
es leuchtet grün sagt jetzt konnten wir
das mit dem iphone und im besten falle
ja es geht da haben sich die hersteller
wohl auch was gut ist bei gedacht dass
das kabel in diesem fall nach links oder
rechts rausgeht und halt nicht so dumm
hier die hand entlanggeht wodurch das
natürlich auch mal diese drehung im
kabel entstehen bis es dann so leicht
aufweist und eben weil dann gar nicht
mehr funktioniert also das finde ich
schon mal ganz gut ich fühle mich gerade
fast wie bei einem werbevideo oder
studium sollte eigentlich nicht
rüberkommen aber daran kann man ja auch
merken dass ich davon begeistert bin und
hier steht dann irgendwo werbevideo oder
so damit dass jetzt aber nicht im
dunklen nervt was man auch das habe ich
auch gelesen eigentlich sollte das jetzt
nämlich nicht mehr leuchten weiß wie ich
meine
also denn so sind oder genau habe ich
zumindest so verstanden
okay da klappt wohl irgendwas mich mein
okay da 3 stellt auch mit einem
technischen facts dazu wir prüfen das
jetzt war auch das sind wirklich ein
unzerstörbares ladekabel ist so wie es
in der werbung gezeigt wurde dazu fangen
wir vielleicht erst mal ganz langsam an
ich habe in der werbung gesehen die
heben damit so eine handliche buch die
weg der bestimmt 30 bis 40 kilo
wir haben uns hier mal eine die junior
benutzt liegt also bei 8
wenn du so machst benutzen
eco flex flexi herr für die weiber
also das sind jetzt zwar keine 40 kilo
aber ich will mal sagen so 15 uhr wird
versuchen diese sitzen wir mit dem nicht
du zurück findet also im fitnessstudio
mache ich eigentlich damit immer so 60
kilo fast immer dein ladekabel mit dabei
ok also das jetzt hat schon mal sie
standhalten die frage es nur lakes noch
er sich schon mal ganz gut aus sagt ja
das funktioniert auch alles
dann testen sie hier ob man das wirklich
nicht durchschneiden kann also also ich
könnte zwar schon durchschneiden sein
messer
das geht jetzt nicht aber mit der schere
also ohne scheiß ich hätte jetzt kaputt
du kannst ja auch mal hier anziehen also
ich kann mir jetzt wirklich nicht
vorstellen dass man damit jetzt auch ein
auto ziehen kann
das würde auseinanderreißen herunter
getrickst wenn er werbung selber zu
erhitzen
ja man zuerst also wird wissen ich meine
erzählt ja nicht umsonst meine tollen
youtube videos die man auf jeden fall
abonnieren sollte weil ich bald eine
million abonnenten ab und noch 8000
stück fehlen oder so deswegen heute
agiert also wir mal versucht aber ich
meine aufziehen kann regel dass 40
kaputt geht ist doch egal dann ist es
also an sich der erste eindruck war ja
wirklich neues und ich kann es euch auch
immer noch als ladekabel empfehlen weil
es halt an sich schon praktisch ist nur
ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gedacht dass
aus dem widerstand hält sehr gut aber
wer schneidet sie ja dann auch schneider
so was durch es war jetzt nur testweise
in der werbung
wenn ich jetzt wieder die hand gebrochen
das funktioniert noch also cook leute
hier ist halt jetzt aufgegangen weil an
sich ich habe mir schon gedacht dass
wenn das so unzerstörbar ist das ist ja
unser außen beschichtung liegt muss und
die kabel die werden jetzt reißen
hast du was zum ziel du musst doch was
zu abschlüssen haben ich weiß nicht ob
du kannst auch leben wo ein haken so ist
in meinem wochen anderes aktion diesmal
wieder super gehen jüngsten denkt man
glaube jetzt kein anderes auto ziehen
so leute da machen wir uns aber trotzdem
noch irgendwann auch wenn ich nichts
sehen kann in der werbung wurde ein auto
gezogen deswegen ist es ja dann auch
nicht so
bad vilbel teste das einfach mal hier
bevor ich mein auto zerstöre
[Musik]
die chance wirklich kaputt dann ist also
mir stellt sich jetzt die frage ob sie
funktioniert hier ist selbst zu reden
und dann war's das schon jetzt glücklich
dass uns nicht kaputt obwohl mir kann es
ja eigentlich egal sein
das ob es geht oder nicht dann habe ich
halt nur eine bewerbung als fake ja gut
aber wer schneidet das den durch alter
ist es wirklich im werbespot auch genau
so dass sie es durchgeschnitten haben
dass sie haben es zumindest versucht mit
der schere
natürlich willst du irgendwie von denen
oder was also ich bin ich bezweifle das
hat jetzt noch geht ist echt stark was
sollst du meinst was geht noch nicht
glauben ja ich sage ja funktioniert doch
ach ich hab ich das glaube ich auch mit
dem nach system der checks immer auf
dieser seite leuchtet es nicht und auf
der anderen seite leuchtet dann kann
man's halt oben drehen passend also ich
finde sie jetzt nicht schlecht so ich
werde auf jeden fall privat weiterhin
benutzen das mit der schere weiß
vielleicht ein bisschen too much hätten
die das in die werbung nicht mit
reingepackt hätte ich jetzt auch nichts
schlechtes was ich sagen kann ich habe
noch eine frage ja steht da irgendwie
nicht schnell das handy auflädt ja das
steht in 24 facher geschwindigkeit wir
können ja mal kurz warten ob das vergeht
ja heute abonniert auf jeden fall alle
vielleicht den kanal instagram heißt
alex wieder freue ich mich immer über
eine menge neue bio ideen und
irgendwelche produkte
wir sehen uns morgen nicht wieder am
morgen des mittwoch dadurch frei sondern
erst donnerstag um 19 uhr das war's mit
dem video und 50 prozent 1 haben wir
schon alles für haupt genau leute herein
[Musik]